so thank you for the introduction it's
nice to be back it's a little weird to
be back because I feel like I should be
dissertate in or something like I'm
supposed to be doing work but I actually
just get to be here to hang out with you
guys and chat so I'm gonna share with
you a bit of research that I've done in
the past and how its leading into some
stuff that's new and in the future and
so I went to that other school across
the bay it was a lot of fun and have
worked at a few places gone to grad
school here worked at a few other places
and volunteered at other places and
landed at UC Santa Cruz right so I've
had this sort of weird career path where
after I finished grad school I just said
I didn't know I want to be a professor
it's a rough life
so I worked at a place that was kind of
amazing which I'll tell you a bit about
in this talk where we were working on
open source robotics right and trying to
make robots more usable by normal people
not just robot whisperers and so I've
had this sort of path through industry
and academia and back to industry where
we see all the same research questions
coming up right and the nice thing about
being able to walk those lines is that
you can be grounded in real world
problems while also drawing upon all the
theory right that we've gotten
human-computer interaction human robot
interaction psychology sociology
anthropology what do we know about
people that we can apply to the design
of technology right so make it better
for us to work for us you may have
noticed the shape of that curve so I'm
actually from not that far away and
Santa Cruz is a little bit like Hawaii
but not quite it's a little colder in
case you don't know where Santa Cruz is
we are where the red star is right now
and it's not that far away I would
encourage you to consider coming to
visit because there's other places that
do fund robotics work too besides just
here on the farm we have you know deer
who get in the way is you're going to
the parking lot they walk in front of my
office all the time the turkeys are also
cute but they're kind of jerks they will
bite your tires if they see you in a car
and we have walkways that look you know
not that bad
Stanford is a beautiful place and that
is a beautiful place too so think about
it it's about 40 minutes drive from here
this is where my office is so and that's
the bike ride home just just a little
bit we are taking applications for our
left
I think you know for me as a social
scientist studying human robot
interaction there was this really
inspiring moment that happened just up
the hill from here where we went from
this sort of space where people thought
computers were these big monstrous
machines and rooms where you had to be a
person with the job of the name computer
in order to make use of that technology
right and you know places like s RI and
in Xerox PARC
right and then at Apple we got to the
point where computers became personal
and usable by end-users people who are
not necessarily trained right so we took
this amazing technology that were sort
of glorified calculators and put them in
the hands of normal people and then we
got to see what they did with that and
it's been pretty amazing now you have
super computers in your pockets and we
take that for granted
I think robotics is not there yet right
robotics is still a space where you
probably want to have a PhD in computer
science robotics if you're gonna do
anything useful with these things and
that's okay but I think a more exciting
future would be one where we can put
these tools in the hands of other people
who are not necessarily trained in these
disciplines to see what they do with it
and so someone who's been working very
actively on that actually this was
invented here the person arm about one
was made of wood even the gears were
made of wood it was an awesome prototype
and the team here was prototyping
different kinds of tasks that these
robots could do around the home right
and this kind of reminds me of Rosie the
robot right there's a reason why it's in
the home and dishwashers and we at
Willow Garage took this idea from Pier
one stole a couple of their PhD students
and made pr2 out of metal and that has
become a research platform that you've
probably seen in a bunch of places and
lots of YouTube videos right from
robotics research labs so we built this
robot and that's what people tend to
point to when they talk about Willow
Garage
bulliraju is in Menlo Park not real far
away but I think what's more important
is the things that we learned from
building that thing first of all people
don't want 500 pound mobile manipulation
robots in their homes they tend to
destroy your carpet and other things too
and we don't really know what they're
for yes but we're working on figuring
that
right and so the things I think that I
learned from that are things that I'm
going to share with you today so yes we
worked on big real robots right 32
degree of freedom all manipulation
platforms but the ones that made it out
into the world as products I think also
teach us a bit of a lesson about you
know how should we take bits of robotics
and bits of autonomy and turn them into
products and services that can help
people today right so I'm going to start
with a little bit of a story he's some
of you heard this before
um so this is a familiar scene probably
especially for those who do you know
remote collaboration and this is my
coworker Dallas Dallas was a voice in a
box on a table as far as I was concerned
right so I would go to meetings and
Dallas would be this like thing talking
in the middle of the desk right and we
would be having discussions about how to
make decisions about you know which
kinds of boards you should be using for
the motor controllers for the big pr2
robot and the way that our electrical
engineering team made decisions at that
time was they would sit at a table and
scream at each other for hours until
somebody won and then they would go with
that decision and if Dallas was
screaming as a voice in a box on the
table and they didn't like what he was
saying they would just hang up on him
right like oh we don't happen right we
lost the connection my bad but by the
way this is the decision we came up with
and like you're gonna have to help us
implement that and so for Dallas it was
not awesome he had some friends in the
company who he'd worked with before he
went to college with them and so they
helped him out a bit so they're like I'm
fine we'll give you a laptop we'll see
her face maybe then I'll be harder for
people to hang up on you right so he was
Skype on a laptop on a cart which
actually was this system and with a
little bit of a better microphone the
normal and bigger speakers we would hear
him maybe present and that worked a
little better it is a little harder to
hang up on someone when they can see you
reach for the power cable but sometimes
we would forget to invite them to the
meeting be like I don't know where the
card is or whatever we don't have time
right or we'd have a conversation in the
kitchenettes
in the morning where we actually do like
the real discussion and then the meeting
we pretend like we're having the
discussion again and making a decision
but actually everything happened outside
of the meeting which is often how it
work
really gets done and so he was still
kind of missing out on a lot of the real
discussion and a lot of the real
decision-making because to us he was
just like some guy who was annoying and
had to be added to meetings right so he
happened to me in town when weekend just
before the big BattleBots competition
because he was a BattleBots competitor
they were busy putting the other table
saw so they could chop up all the other
robots in the stadium as they were
chopping those things up he decided to
steal some body parts from our pr2 and
the following Monday this is Dallas
actually coming in to work looking like
that with a big lead acid battery in the
base a very expensive caster in the back
stolen from the pr2 and here he can now
pounce on us to ask us questions that he
already asked us an email but this time
you actually need to answer because if
you don't he's not gonna get out of that
doorway and leave you alone right and so
now that you're a mobile robot in his
space with the face nobody's gonna shut
you off unless they're actually a really
close friend and that's cool to do and
so Dallas became this robot in our world
that we talked to and hung out with
every day and now to be totally honest I
thought it was stupid the first time
that I saw it it's like that
that's so gimmicky right and like the
only reason that we like it is because
we like robots and we like him he's
actually kind of a nice person but over
time what we learned was that he's
really a person like we got to meet his
kids because of our time zone
differences his kids would drive around
in the office about 4:00 p.m. when we
played pool he would come in hang out
with us he would sometimes go and like
hide our trash cans from us just to
screw with us in the middle of the night
right um and he became a human he became
a friend and a colleague and so then
when we had big discussions we were
yelling at each other in the room we'd
actually listen to him right and so even
though it feels like this touchy-feely
thing we're like yeah you're getting to
know him that's cool whatever actually
he was more effective at his job because
of this because he had more presence
because it was really hard for us to
ignore him and turn him off when we
didn't want to listen to him right so
then the question became okay we're
supposed to be building these big robots
that are really fancy and do everything
that ROS the robot did but we're
actually finding a lot of value in doing
this too so this became a little skunk
or side project where the team decided
to build
few more those they got a slightly
better set of skins those are still you
know it's just Skype on a stick on
wheels right and so I know the robot
assist in the room we're gonna say
that's not a robot fine whatever
you can add lighter to it we did have
holy-o's down here so you could do you
know some obstacle avoidance but I think
the real question was is anyone gonna
use it can they use it is it gonna be
valuable not to be worth putting up with
the hassle of dealing with these systems
and that's when they turn to me and
they're like Lela you deal with humans
you gonna figure this out right so I
went and dealt with the humans and my
job became to field these out in the
world I will say just you know because
this is an academic classroom we did not
invent this right these systems have
existed for decades before we ever did
this at Willow Garage so I think the
earliest one was trauma the personal
roving presence or the proper system
made about Eric policy at UC Berkeley
and I remember when we first started
talking about this work with Eric he's
like thank you for finally doing the
user studies that my adviser said I
should have done but I didn't because it
was too much of a pain in the butt and
actually back then so in the 90s if you
tried to do video conferencing you know
so streaming video and audio up and down
constantly in a building you would bring
down the network in the building within
about 10 minutes right and so I think
just at that time the wireless networks
weren't prepared for that kind of demand
and that kind of load but by the time we
were doing it it was kind of sort of
doable another really fun one that I
like is where'd it go over here this was
HP Labs and you'll see they actually had
a 360-degree view of the person so you
could identify them even for the back of
their heads right if they're walking
down the hallway that thing was so wide
that it barely fit through doorways but
it did really fit through doorways so it
was kind of it was fine I had a much
larger girth of course because of that
so there's a bunch of design trade-offs
here to think about right when you're
building these systems there's now more
products on the market where these
things are really being built right and
so because the wireless networks are
ready because you don't actually need to
have a ton of autonomy to make this work
it's a product hospitals are using them
for doctors to do rounds right so if you
have a specialist who the patient needs
to see but your particular clinic
doesn't have that kind of specialists
around they can use one of these systems
to let those doctors come in check
right with the help of the nurses and
other staff a lot of folks also do
remote work right use these systems
these are earlier prototypes of systems
that have since been checked I will say
it's a little weird to have someone
talking to your chest those designs have
sort of you know disappeared now but
we're learning over time you know what
is a socially appropriate way of talking
to someone via a robot which is what a
lot of our studies were about there are
other ways being remotely present right
and so you know if you're easy girlís
doesn't say you can make an android that
looks just like yourself right but that
also means that now your grand grad
students could puppeteer you just say
whatever they want you to say and
another challenge with this right is you
now need to have an Android for every
person right each person needs to be
replicated and inexpensive the system
but you do get to look like yourself
which is pretty cool another challenge
that we've been learning about is that
you age but your robot doesn't at least
not the same way right like our rubber
doesn't fall apart but our hair changes
like sometimes you gain a little weight
get little chubbier and your robot
doesn't and people can still compare you
so there's challenges here and you know
when I've talked with these eager about
this he's like it's this is the best
system your robots are creepy can I tell
him no ours is the best system your
robot that's creepy I think this isn't
creepy er so one of the challenges that
we posed was okay now you got a build
room for every single person and so
their answer to that was well you just
make a baby right because babies are
like anonymous people that could turn
into anybody sort of like a tamagotchi
right and so you know you can talk to
your grandma on the robot that looks
like that and that will solve the
problem and I think I don't understand
but I think you know there are there are
different cultural backgrounds that we
are coming from that make things more or
less socially acceptable so I think I
just don't get it
but this is a possible design direction
right and folks like here so Osama has
been working on some really cool robots
that look like humanoids in the ocean
and you know there are places where
maybe you do want it to look like a
person because then you can tele operate
it more effectively right so if I can't
scuba dive at the depths that we need to
be able to scuba dive to get
samples from the ocean that we want
right maybe it doesn't make sense to
make systems that move like we do so
that I have a more natural understanding
of how to control that thing right that
might be one argument for going in this
direction so nothing is bad I'm just
saying there's a lot of there's a big
design space we happen to pick one
direction it might be wrong right it
kind of depends on what you're trying to
achieve for that end user what is the
goal of the task so when I talk about
these systems I made up some vocabulary
if you catch me saying local I mean the
person who is proximate to the system so
in the same physical space if you catch
me saying remote pilot I'm talking about
the person like Dallas right who's in
Indiana but coming here in California
via robot so the question was is anyone
gonna use it
are we just weird nerds who like robots
right and that's why we're using this
thing or is there something valuable
there that other people could actually
make you so right we already have video
conferencing it works pretty well is
this gonna be any better and so I
fielded over a dozen of these over time
and for much longer than this by the end
of the study but at the beginning of the
study we got to publish some of that
work and I can share that with you here
today so we looked at three different
companies not our own it took a long
time to get NDA's in place and they let
us shadow them for many months just to
see how they use it or don't use it
right so we weren't pushing their
product onto them we said like here just
borrow this thing see if you want it I
understood all of these sites they had
those big video conferencing systems up
in the walls for public spaces they were
all shut off for various reasons so I do
think that there are some limitations of
current video conferencing that don't
make persistent presence work that well
their physical robot bodies were all
located here in the San Francisco Bay
Area because these are prototypes and
they break all the damn time but the
remote pilots were actually remote my
favorite remote pilot was actually here
in Singapore he was everybody's favorite
sysadmin who would fix things at 2:00
a.m. because 2:00 a.m. for him is
different than 2:00 a.m. for us right
and so they'd send him emails whenever
they wanted and they'd come into work in
the morning and be done that was great
for their team and when he visited in
person he seriously got like hugs and
high-fives from everybody because he was
everybody's favorite sysadmin he was not
everybody's favorite sysadmin for the
cleaning staff who we forgot to brief at
the
in Mozilla right so you can imagine but
you're used to we had done a brown bag
talk where we gave people a heads up
like hey there's gonna be this thing
rolling around your space it's not it
doesn't have guns don't worry about it
right but we didn't warn the folks who
were gonna be there in the middle of the
night because we didn't know that they
were there and so for them it was
actually kind of terrifying to see like
a dude rolling around watching them do
their work when normally it was quiet in
the space over them was super upsetting
so that was a mistake that we learned
from right like you actually needs a
debrief everyone everyone not just the
people are gonna be interacting with it
during the day what do they do with
these systems right the first thing is
you know they kind of do what they do
when they're in the office in person
right this is not really that different
from the chitchat that normally happens
in offices I think what's more
interesting than what they're doing is
where they were doing it and so if you
look at the physical locations in the
office where they're talking right
usually we use fancy videoconferencing
systems like this one in big formal
meeting spaces right so I like a lecture
hall or a boardroom or meeting room with
like the fancy tables these are used in
informal communication spaces right so
remember the kitchenette where the real
conversation happens before the meeting
where everyone actually makes decisions
right are you chat about the weekend so
you can get too near coworkers as people
and so of Justice transactive coworkers
right and so the best space actually to
talk with folks tends to be right when
they've started to make their coffee
because they're stuck for at least a
minute right while their coffee is
dripping and so you can chit chat with
them and it'd be kind of rude for them
to walk away and be like I'm busy I'm
waiting for my coffee right instead
they're gonna maybe give you a chance
till I get to know them so there's
different tactics for using these
systems in previous work that has looked
at videoconferencing right so body Nardi
has done a lot of work in the CSC
w-space i'm computer-supported
cooperative work where they find that
teleconferencing systems basically
support three things which are these and
I'll go through each in turn and robots
robot media communication is kind of
similar so the first thing that we see
is that when people bother to show up
right when you put that butt in that
chair in our presence and taking notes
and participating you're communicating
to your team that you
about your project you care about your
shared goals you get better outcomes
usually out of those types of
collaborations so this was actually the
director for Firefox so his team was in
Mountain View
he lived in Toronto and normally what he
would do is log in to that video camera
in the back of the room so kind of like
these cameras here the problem with that
is that no one else gets to see you the
audience who's in that camera right but
if you show up in robot which is
actually a pain in the butt to do
because it was a prototype your
teammates then feel like you care more
they're more likely to come and chat
with you afterwards right turns out that
he was actually blocking the view of the
woman behind him because his head was
too big which we never figured out a
good solution for but as a team overall
right they felt better about him being
their director right because they could
just chat with him he was more just like
a person who was present in who cared
another thing that I briefly touched on
earlier right is you can get people's
attention when you send an email that's
just some text on the screen that
someone can ignore they might ignore it
but when you roll into someone's office
and block their doorway until you they
answer you answer their question you're
probably gonna answer
you're probably gonna talk to them and
if you don't leave until you feel like
it right it's kind of like someone just
barging into your office or pouncing on
you in the hallway same thing right they
can keep your attention longer than they
could through other media I did learn
over time how to hear that robot coming
because there's this like really
high-pitched sound that the motor
controllers would make and so sometimes
if I didn't want to talk to Dallas and I
heard him coming you could like run out
the door of the building because he
can't open doors I think which is my
workaround for that problem it's kind of
like hearing footsteps right
you can sometimes tell who the person is
who's coming into your office and decide
if you want to pretend like you're there
or not same thing
later on we used these hub motors that
are silent that screwed up my plan so
then they could pounce on you whenever
they really wanted and that was a little
startling so actually you do want a
little bit of noise because people make
noise right we hear you coming you know
just somebody up here behind someone
that's creepy last bit that super
important is this hanging out and
building real social connections getting
to know your co-workers as people right
as full people not just the person that
you sit with and sit across the meeting
room table from around 5 o'clock or
sometimes 4
o'clock on Fridays our team would often
start playing pool just because it was a
thing to do this is a super warped table
that was not that great and quite
frankly the robots would kick our butts
playing this because geometry is easy
for robots and hard for people but they
just do it for fun nobody was very good
at it and if you were there via robot
you don't get to play pool because you
don't have arms you could have arms you
still probably won't be that good but
you can heckle the people who are
playing pool right and that's just
something that coworkers do it's how you
build rapport it's how you build
relationships and that kind of
relationship is what makes it possible
to have difficult conversations later on
when you need to without feeling like
you're really being threatened you
understand that everyone's on the same
side when you've hung out together a
bunch and you can get through the hard
stuff you can work through the hard
stuff better and more effectively once
you've met in person and hung out so you
know all those things sort of gave us
some evidence that maybe there's
something there and so we spun out a
company called suitable technologies
that was in Palo Alto just got purchased
this is the interface that came out
during that time it's not awesome but it
was a lot worse before I promise so you
dragged your body around with the others
graphical user interface the first
version was a web browser-based
interface and then we just I do a native
one people tend to forget what they look
like when they're a robot and so we
remind them by putting mirrors around
the space that actually ended up being
really important because people are not
good at presenting themselves to be a
robot and so that was what came out of
sort of that work right there's enough
confidence to say like maybe there's
something there if you have seen shell
but no we did not rip off shell but
Shawmut was our robot I always get this
question so the folks who do the Big
Bang Theory show really really do their
homework like they're they're real nerds
they found our YouTube video of the
first prototypes when like nobody cared
or was looking at it and they called up
our team and they said hey we want to
use your robot for one of our episodes
is that cool and our team was so giddy
with excitement that we dropped
everything that we were doing to help
them do this shoot and actually Kurt
Meyers who was on this team the core
team that developed this he was on that
BattleBots group
he loves the Big Bang Theory so much
that he had their theme song as his
wedding march down the aisle so when
these guys called it
was freakin awesome right and so yes we
dropped everything to do this show the
robot was not perfect right so the
screen wasn't really that bright right
if you've seen you know old displays
like that and so they had to shoot the
entire episode almost in the dark so
that the screen will be bright enough
relative to everybody else's faces but
it kind of worked
Steve Wozniak was the guest actor on
this particular episode so he signed the
back of its head
and we still have that robot today so
that's kind of cool people do weird
things crazy things that we never would
have expected with these robots um
anybody know who that guy is
yeah Snowden there are people who do not
want to be in the United States
physically because they will get
arrested and but they do want to be able
to get talks right so their message is
heard and so it turns out you can use
telepresence robots for that cuz like
who cares if they arrest the robot right
fine whatever I'm so good and so he used
it to give a TED talk which works that
is not a use case that we had
anticipated like it's not until you put
this stuff out in the world and you see
the crazy things that people do that you
start to understand like what's it
really for right and so stuff like that
happens and you learn from it which is
kind of neat so I said you know we learn
from the real world we do I do
exploratory field studies because for me
that's the best inspiration for finding
like what are the important questions
here right and so based on those
questions we from hypotheses about what
if we designed it if this way what if we
designed it that way right how might we
make it better and so to test those
hypotheses you run controlled
experiments so these look like psych
experiments except instead of only
having people you throw in a robot or
two also and see what happens
behaviorally and attitudinal II you
learn from those studies you figure out
how those design changes actually affect
user experience and use of the system
build a new prototype right integrating
those lessons and then rinse and repeat
right we filled those prototypes learn
from them so I'm gonna give you just a
couple of examples of these so you have
a flavor of what that looks like so in
human robot interaction we tend to be
very empirical right we tend to work a
lot with designers and other folks who
know how to study humans as well as
roboticists who know how to what's
possible to build right what is really
doable in the near future
before I go that actually are there any
questions on that first set of studies
you good okay cool so controlled
experiments um the ultimate design goal
of the system is to make people feel
like the remote coworkers are actually
part of the team right so in social
psychology we call that in-group
behavior as opposed to out group
behavior right so if you go to big game
right and you are on the Stanford side
the red shirts are your in-group and the
blue shirts of the out-group right and
we tend to actually mark that with
uniforms right it's a very powerful
visual cue to tell you who's on your
side and who's not who used to should
you throw the football to and who should
you not throw the football to right
pretty clear it turns out that if you do
this with computers it does almost the
exact same thing to humans as does when
you do this to people so if I give you a
blue wristband and I tell you you're on
the blue team randomly assigned like you
just you're blue and now I give you a
little blue border and I tell you put
that around the frame of your computer
screen just desktop you will be nicer to
that computer you will spend more time
with it and you would think it's more
competent then if I put a red border
around it it's silly its irrational we
know that that thing is not a human it's
not really a teammate that's not even
really my team because you just told me
what team has on but it works
consistently with pretty much all humans
right so we have this innate need to
know who is part of us who is one of us
and who is not and we tend to extend it
to other things besides just people
that's all work that my advisor did here
at Clifford Nass when we were in the
communication department and so we
decided like alright let's try this with
robots cuz you know what works with
computers it'll be great right we've got
the blue person we've got the blue robot
everything's gonna be good we'll all be
friends
this study proved me wrong so we do this
study with Irene ray and Billy moot Lou
or at University of Wisconsin Madison at
the time Irene was interning with us and
we're like okay we're gonna bring people
into the room they're gonna decorate the
robot they'll have a discussion about a
topic where they disagree and see if
they can come to more agreement and at
the end we'll do a questionnaire so this
is what that study looked like they came
into the study we randomly assigned them
to the condition where they personalized
the system we gave them the stuff to
personalize it with or not then we have
them do a task where
people think that they should know the
answers so we use the desert survival
task which is a lot of fun because
everybody always gets an answer wrong
but they're super confident in their
answer so you tell them this cover story
of ok let's say that you're in the
desert you're on a bus tour and your bus
crashes you have these 10 items to
survive your job is to rank them in
order of importance for your survival
and you would like to think that we know
what items are important for our
survival most people really don't but
they do feel very strongly about their
answers and so you have them do that
individually then you put them in a room
and you have them discuss with a remote
participant actually a Confederate in
our case and then you have them rank the
items again to see if their new answers
align more with their partners or if
they just stick to their guns right
they're like now I got the right answer
and then we do a disclosure interview at
the end and chat with them about what
their experience was like so what
happened we did a between participant
study meaning that each of the people in
these cells was only in one condition of
the study right they didn't do all of
them so we had people who did not
decorate the robot we had people who did
decorate the robot we also tried a
framing that we know works for in group
behavior which is you tell them at the
end of this study we're gonna grade your
performance on just your answer so as
long as you're right you get all the
points or we're gonna grade both of your
answers as a team you're
interdependently scored because we know
this can work and we want to see how it
compares with decorating versus not
decorating we expected right that if you
tell people we're gonna score both of
you together interdependent scoring that
you would be more in Group E with your
partner then if you are independently
scored and we do see evidence of that so
people will disclose more information
about themselves if they're told that
their final performance scores are
interdependent this makes me a little
sad but as humans if we feel like
someone is an out-group member we tend
to attribute more animal-like emotions
to them animal-like are things that are
basic right so anger fear happiness
human-like emotions and more things like
angst right they're a little more
nuanced and so if you notice that people
attribute more animal-like emotions to a
team that you don't really care about
that tends to indicate that's an
accurate member they also say that they
like the pilot
they're interdependent that's kind of a
no duh so the manipulation that
manipulation worked the thing we really
cared about right was if we do this blue
team red team thing and let people
decorate it to look like themselves are
they gonna be nicer to that person and
treat them more like an Ingram member
the answer is no and like big fat no
with statistical significance no so what
ended up happening in our data was that
if you decorated the robot you did not
cooperate as much with your partner and
you don't really want to talk to them as
much after the end of the study that
hurt but you know as experimentalist you
need to be open to all the possibilities
out there and so you know what are the
competing hypotheses that might have
predicted this results when we did the
debriefing with these participants what
they told us pretty consistently was
this if they're in the decorating
condition they're like yeah the remember
was really cool I really liked it it was
so it was so interesting to see but like
who's that guy who was in the screen why
are they in my robot right and so they
were actually building relationships
with the machine right the proxy but not
with the person on the other side and so
that's why we think it backfired on us
right and so yes cliff was right right
computers or social actors robots or
social actors but in the telepresence
situation where the actor is actually a
person inside of a machine they seem to
actually be orienting more towards the
machine one way we think that we might
be able to fix this right is instead of
having the local person just decorate a
machine and then have some random person
log into it is you have the person log
into it and they chat and together they
decorate the machine right so it's more
like an activity that's done together as
opposed to one that's done independently
and that's actually some follow-up work
that we've been doing with folks at USC
to look at you know this decorating
thing it just keeps happening when
people get robots they want to put stuff
on it to customize it for themselves and
so what are the psychological effects of
those kinds of interactions so don't let
people decorate the robot before the
telepresence folks log in another
question that came up a lot was around
this so people suck at driving robots
especially robots that have weird
configurations like ours where it drives
like a forklift right forklift drivers
good forklift drivers are really hard to
find it turns out good telepresence or
about drivers are hard - it is hard to
walk and talk and that is the thing
you're supposed to do with this thing so
yours it would happen is people would
drive around kind of like bumble into
place and they get to a meeting room and
then they just sit there still and just
be a face on the screen right and the
whole point of having presents it's
physical presence here is you don't have
to do that that you could move around if
you wanted to you could be more alive
and more present in the space but it's
hard to do it and so what if we added
autonomous assistance right so at least
a little bit of say obstacle avoidance
to help people like not make mistakes
and so we use that little lighter on the
base and you know it's just doing a
little sweep at this level and so you
could probably avoid things like table
legs or chairs or trash cans right walls
doors definitely and so we created a
cost map around the space of the robot
and so if I as the pilot tried to drive
into this desk it wouldn't let me it
would actually like replan my path
around there so I'd still get to where
I'm trying to go but it would make me
not make mistakes and hit stuff so it's
pretty simple algorithms the question
that was is it going to work and is it
going to work when humans have it in
their hands so we made an obstacle
course an office space right because
that was the kind of space that we're
looking at we put lots of things in its
way like chairs and trash cans and
boards and we told people you know go
ahead and practice as much as you want
until you feel comfortable with it and
then let us know when you're ready to go
and we measured how fast they could do
the obstacle course and how many things
they hit so time on tasks and error rate
sort of standard performance metrics
here we did the controlled experiment we
randomly assigned people to one of two
conditions we're either they have no
autonomous assistance we just turned the
lighter off or they do have autonomous
assistance where we don't let them run
into things we also measured one other
thing because we were worried that it
was going to matter
turned out it did there's this
personality dimension from personality
psychology from the 70s called locus of
control and here this this is all about
how much control you feel like you
should be in in the world so if you have
a very strong
Journal locus of control you probably
believe things like you know stuff just
happens fate you know things things go
as they go and you know I'm not really
the one who's going to be controlling
that right I roll with the punches if
you have a strong internal locus of
control in contrast you believe that you
are the master of your own destiny
if you succeed it is because you're
amazing if you fail it's because you're
terrible
right you believe that you're in control
of what happens in the world most people
fall somewhere along this continuum so
we measured this as a personality
dimension and then we put people into
two buckets depending on the median
split so what do we expect to find our
hypothesis was that if you have obstacle
wins don't hit fewer things let's hope
that works right the other thing that we
hoped was that you could drive faster
right so you shouldn't be able to do the
task better if you've got assistance it
turns out that yeah if you have obstacle
once you hit fewer things they still
managed to hit one thing I'm not sure
why maybe it was below the level of the
lighter but you know that's a big
statistical significant difference
that's the big effect size um that was
the surprising one though for us so if
you have autonomous assistance so that
you won't hit things in this off so of
course it actually takes you longer to
finish than if you don't have autonomous
assistance which kind of goes counter to
what we would expect so we dug them to
the data a little deeper right we looked
at that other variable so locus of
control right I am the master of my own
destiny I believe in fate and roll with
the punches so it turns out that if you
need to be in control
you don't like to give up control to
robots if you give me autonomous
assistance but I don't want your
stinking autonomous assistance because I
want to be in control
I take longer to finish that obstacle
course and more specifically this is the
one that stands out as statistically
it's my feeling different than the other
three right so here's the place where
things blow up this is very probably the
person who really loves driving a stick
shift car but you force them into an
automatic they get frustrated they're
like if I want to hit the trashcan I'm
gonna hit the trashcan watch me hit the
trashcan right and there they're showing
you that they're frustrated by
performing worse right they're like I
want to cut that corner sharper than
it's letting me cut it I want to let me
do it I'm gonna try that
more time right and so behaviorally
we're actually seeing a performance
decrement for those folks which is
important to think about as we're
designing increasingly autonomous
systems right offering more assistance
that you know that what they're intended
to help they're intended to make us do
better to drive better to fly planes
better but if you've got the wrong
personality type matched with that
autonomous assistance you can get into
trouble yeah question so you told them
by the way we have this extra autonomous
thing that's going to be course
correcting
it doesn't strike you as an option to
just sort of make it subtle enough that
it could still improve oh yeah we could
not tell them and see what happens that
would be an interesting follow-up study
I think another one that can be cool is
like what if we give the manual override
right because that's currently that's
often a design decision and depending on
what sort of your company believes a pet
is the right thing to do you could offer
that yeah I think there's a bunch of
different variations that we couldn't
probably should do on studies like these
to figure out really you know how is it
that the human dimensions are gonna be
interacting with these autonomous
systems that we're building because yes
autonomy it can be amazing but if
there's a human in the loop that's gonna
fight it and it's gonna make the entire
system performance worse right so I
think yeah think about the framing is
super important you maybe don't want to
tell them like by the way we're gonna
take control away from you and they're
going to give it back to you right you
might just say like it's just a co-pilot
it's just helping you out you don't have
to listen to it if you don't want to
yeah internal focus guys if they hit
more objects they didn't get assistance
and exercise so you're talking about
internal locus guys with no assistance
versus these guys yeah that one is not
statistically significantly different
these are but I mean in terms of hitting
obstacles so they actually uh oh I see
yes there we didn't season a few
differences um so if I didn't show the
chart that's because there was like too
much noise in the data to see it but
maybe if we made the course harder right
or maybe if we change the precision of
the obstacle avoidance it might be
different that'd be an interesting thing
to look at - yeah and of course like the
you know what are the consequences of
hitting a trashcan like not real big but
if you think about cars and you hit a
dog right that's a bigger consequence or
even worse than that so I think you know
people are more careful in different
situations depending on what
the consequences are here I will say one
weird thing that I keep seeing with
these telepresence robots is I think
because it's a remote location from
where your physical body is sometimes
they don't take it so seriously and so
we've had people log into these robots
and like chase down our coworkers
because I think it's fun
I think cuz it feels like a game right
and the interface is a little bit
game-like and so we would have to sell
them like please don't run over that
person like that's not nice like that's
a real person they will actually bleed
and it will actually hurt right and so I
think there are some important things
that we need to explore there around
responsibility and like really
understanding the consequences of our
actions I think the same is gonna be
true for other remote-controlled systems
- yeah that's a great question any
others on this one before we move on so
I will say I totally did not do this
stuff on my own I've had an amazing set
of collaborators on these projects these
are just a few of them they come from
also amazing places right and so this is
not work that like one person does on
their own right doing especially field
studies you need to have a large team of
people to get that stuff done right like
spreading out across ten companies to
shadow people as they're doing their
work talking with them about difficult
things going on it takes time and people
and resources right so of course we
never do this stuff on our own